helping news to start with though here  at six there's been a series of  earthquakes overnight in central nevada  yeah there have been at least  50 earthquakes since one o'clock this  morning this is near the  tonopah and mina area sort of very  northern parts of nye county  most of them are very small one of them  did measure 5.5 though  earthquakes have been pretty common in  that area we've seen clusters of these  before  no reports of any injuries or major  damage you'll remember sherry  the last time they had some rather more  serious earthquakes up there that  damaged the highway up there they had to  have some detours around there so  it is possible but it looks like this is  just sort of a little more excessive  shaking yeah